we can't really be pitted against each
other right and
when we when we have these conversations
and i read a lot of these comments with
some with some kids they're like
well this is why i didn't support blm
because they're out here
you know killing us or whatever right
and the only thing i could say to that
is that
you can go ahead and find a lot of the
negative things if you want to find it
but if you look in my comments
like 30 40 is black people saying like
hey we got your back i'm sorry this
happened
this [ __ ] is unacceptable um
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the
genius brain podcast i am your host
david soh
and we have once again our co-host
ed drick park back again y'all
jazz hands baby well this has been a
very
interesting past couple of weeks because
a lot of people have asked
me to talk about what's been going on
specifically with the asian american
community and a lot of the attacks that
have been happening
um and you know when it was first
happening i didn't really say much
yeah just because it was number one i
think
it was so shocking you know because when
i picture somebody getting attacked
i picture some young person you know
getting [ __ ] up by some dudes or
whatever right
or maybe i don't know maybe he did
something to provoke something i don't
know what it is you know when you think
of an attack you don't think
of one a minor or an elderly
when we say elderly i'm talking about
the biggest one of all was the 84 year
old man who was just walking
he was walking in front of a garage or
maybe his complex and this kid
um antoine something i can't remember
his name right now
maybe it's because i've been so enraged
but he literally shoves this man
full force as hard as possible and he
actually
dies from the trauma from when he was
shoved
and the crazy thing about that whole
situation was like
i couldn't wrap my head around why yeah
it's like
what why and people are saying or i
think i read they're they're it's
leaning that it was actually racially
charged
obviously because of the whole you know
the nation's perspective on asian people
because of the coronavirus and yeah and
a lot of other [ __ ] right
and you know when this happened a lot of
people were like you aren't saying
things why aren't you saying something
you were so loud for blm it's like
listen here you little [ __ ] face me some
[ __ ] time
you know what i mean like let me think
about what the [ __ ] i'm going to say
yeah i don't think you guys understand
like this obviously hits a lot closer to
home
and because these attacks were happening
so frequently it was like
would you say it was a string of like 20
something yeah i think there was a 20 to
30 attacks in the span of like two weeks
that and
and like i was saying it wasn't even
hitting mainstream news you know this is
just happening
um and so it's it's just one of those
things where you like
you let's remove the race part out of it
first
and just think why the [ __ ] would you
want to attack an elderly person
like they're helpless they're so [ __ ]
defenseless
you know and the fact that a fall could
end their life
i don't know if if the people who are
attacking necessarily realize even if
they don't realize that there's still
no [ __ ] excuse yeah it was hard to
wrap around and every time i i felt like
i was gonna say something somebody else
got attacked somebody else got attacked
so i just had to keep processing and
processing and so when it comes to a
topic like this that's very heavy
um and it's a lot more personal i have
so much [ __ ] to process because first it
was like anger then it was sadness and
it was questioning why
and so you know one of the biggest
points that i wanted to get across to a
lot of people is shut the [ __ ] up
like you know some people process things
differently
and i think the odd thing was and i this
is for and i call
these these young kids who do this you
guys are yelp elite people
you are the people who pride themselves
in being a yelp elite and the reason why
i make that comparison
is because you are the type of people
that will go to an establishment or in
this case a person
and attack somebody who is actually
going through the same [ __ ] that you're
going because it's an easier target
it's easier to go ahead and try to yell
at me and say why aren't you saying
anything
rather than you going out and saying
something yourself yeah you're a little
[ __ ]
you're you're the exact same thing you
know you're a little [ __ ]
to be fair to be fair i think that the
people who are requesting
a response from you definitely falls
into different schools though right
some might just be wanting just because
they look up to you
to hear your personality i'm not talking
about those people yeah i'm talking
about the ones that are [ __ ]
attacking
right right not just me you [ __ ]
yeah
it's like yo bro like chill yeah you
can't how are you going to say i am four
asian americans and then attacking
an asian american like you don't make
any [ __ ] sense you're a [ __ ] yelp
elite reviewer
not to mention bro it's just like
sometimes man
given the state of things and like what
we've been through in the past year or
so
it's exhausting you know what i mean
like it's exhausting to keep talking
about [ __ ]
that brings you down that that you know
gives you grief like it puts you in such
a negative space
like dude we're [ __ ] human beings too
man sometimes
like we're aware that shit's going on
but just for our
own mental health and like our own sake
we need to kind of separate ourselves
from it a little bit distance it from a
little bit
and then once we're kind of in a space
we're like okay that's something i can
absorb
and like kind of uh digest a little bit
better now that i'm gonna i feel like
i'm in a better space but then
it's like you know instant gratification
world yeah well it's it's this idea
that a lot of young people have i'm
sorry not young people i'm gonna stop
saying that just people in general have
that you get to [ __ ] on somebody because
it's easier
you know you want that pat on your back
oh did you know i was the one that
called out all these asian american
influencers
you are masturbating to your wokeness
and i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
people process things differently and if
the objective is for us to uplift each
other
do you think that the first thing that
you should do is go ahead and attack
another asian american verbally that
doesn't make [ __ ] sense
you're a trash bag you literally make no
sense
if you have that energy go ahead and do
it into something positive because by
the way
a huge issue that i have too is that you
guys expect
these celebrities who by the way aren't
some sometimes
aren't the best people to talk about
anything right because just because they
are known for something doesn't mean
that they're smart
i actually don't want some of these
people to say anything at all i want
them to shut the [ __ ] up and let smarter
people speak
which can be a lot of you a lot of you
have the same platform that we
we do it may not be as large as ours but
there's also power in numbers for sure
it starts somewhere man yeah don't sit
and wait for us to do something like
i said on my instagram story it's going
to happen but you have to let me think
about these things because i
do have a bigger platform so the things
that i say
can be more impactful so i can't just go
off and start saying
[ __ ] you i hate you blah blah blah we
can do all that but i need to say
something at the end
that stuff is only effective if i have a
proper message so
you know moving on from that [ __ ] you
you know be smart about what you guys
are doing um
so there was the 84 year old time man
there was the filipino man who was like
slashed across his face with a knife
yeah which shocked me there was the
there was one guy who attacked
multiple uh elder elderly people in
chinatown in oakland
um last year there was a person that was
uh they doused this person in flames
they put um
like oil or alcohol on this older lady
and just lit her on fire
yeah it's just been kind of crazy how
frequent it's been and
what a lot of people don't know is that
older asian americans are easier targets
because we all know this
you know our parents would rarely ever
call the cops number one they think it's
too much trouble
or number two there's a language barrier
yeah right so they're very very easy
targets and specifically right now
lunar new year is coming up they're
expecting a lot of these uh
older asian people to have cash and
money on them so they're trying to rob
them
right so there's this idea and concept
and
and if you guys don't know this is
something that you should know and if
nobody's gonna
nobody's gonna protect our community
except for us
we can't just wait for somebody else to
do it we are 5.6
of this of this country's population
very very [ __ ] small
and i think we don't get to see that
because we live in california right
and so i see a lot of people saying like
well where are the cops what are they
going to do let me tell you something
about the cops
there's not a lot of them right and so
when these things happen you have to be
there first if you know about these type
of situations and you see things
happening
and i'm not saying that you have to do
things in an aggressive manner and get
angry
but you have to be mindful and know
about these things so you can't help
when it's needed oh for sure
and and uh the strange thing is is that
it's it's happening
in um you know a pretty concentrated
area of
asian glen san francisco and the asian
people in in those communities
which is kind of strange to begin with
because uh there's a
pretty big asian community out there
um but either way the fact that
it's racially charged and they're
targeting elderly people it's
it's so despicable and so cowardly man
like
when i first started seeing the stuff
about it it just
it pissed me off that was my first
reaction because i'm like dude what if
that was my grandpa or my grandma
or my mom and my dad i mean they're
getting older now too so
ah like the first thing thoughts you
have is
kind of like what you would do to
retaliate you know what i mean or like
if you were there
and you saw it happen what you would do
um but
you know you can't you can't match
violence with violence right you got to
kind of let the
the initial i guess anger subside and
think about it more reasonably but
yeah i think they should make more of an
effort
to to really kind of band together so
that there's more of like
a sort of neighborhood watch type of
thing like a a sense of community yeah
yeah
so that if you spot an elderly
asian person since that's kind of like
the target profile for
for these attackers just be a little bit
more aware
you know what i mean if you see them
walking around in the streets or
whatever
and there's a lot of nuance to this
because i know it's it's it's
it's really difficult right because when
we say asian and i've talked about this
on the podcast before
there is an issue of a language barrier
thing right yeah that we're going to
have to work past because when we say
asian
you have any idea how many languages and
cultures that is
right yes so it's like even sometimes
too like i remember
even like sometimes trying to when when
an elder like chinese lady would come up
to me and she would start speaking to me
in cantonese or mandarin
and i can't even help her but she sees a
familiar face
it gets lost in translation i'm still
trying to help this lady out yeah and i
feel like a lot of like elder asian
people have experienced that so it's
hard for them to reach out for help
and it's hard for them to communicate
with people for sure so when these
things happen they never report this to
the cops
right and so if they're even alive to
report it you know what i mean
and that's that's it's just a really
[ __ ] up situation right
so the the idea that
we have to wait for this savior to come
and help us out it's just not going to
happen
like it's even hard for us to help each
other out because we're all so different
korean americans to japanese americans
to vietnamese americans to korean
america to uh to i don't know
um some other [ __ ] [ __ ] some indian
americans yeah
i just got lost i got lost in the sauce
right there it's like korean american
vegetarian
north korea you know
but that that's the that's the thing
that uh and i'm not saying this too by
the way that
these cultures can't empathize with
somebody else when they get hurt that's
completely not what i'm saying
what i'm saying is that that
communication level is also a hurdle
that we have to get through
you know and so when this happens too
like there's also been another issue
like one of the bigger things is like uh
that's been very conflicting for a lot
of people is that
a lot of the people that have been
attacking asian americans that have been
put out
through media or whether social media
has been a lot of black americans
right and this was a very like weird and
touchy subject for a lot of people to go
ahead and number one february is black
history month
right number two is also chinese new
year it's also chinese new year at the
same time right
and so um the the weird thing is
is like we can't really be pitted
against each other right
and when we when we had these
conversations and i read a lot of these
comments with some with some
kids they're like well this is why i
didn't support blm because they're out
here
you know killing us or whatever right
and the only thing i could say to that
is that you can go ahead and find a lot
of the negative things if you want to
find it but if you look in my comments
like 30 40 is black people saying like
hey we got your back i'm sorry this
happened
this [ __ ] is unacceptable um
and that's what i'm gonna look towards
right because as of right now
like like people are trying to make this
thing
like a race or a race war like pro-age
in order for you to be pro-asian you
have to be anti-black because
the stuff that we've seen so far is from
young black americans right
specifically male black americans right
and
that's a very very dangerous territory
to walk into
number one because you can't judge a
whole
ethnic group based on the actions of a
few individuals
right that goes for all the stuff that's
happened that we've said this stuff with
cops we can't say that all cops are bad
because of a few individuals we can talk
about the institution
we can also talk about in this case of
how little
a lot of like asian americans are
respected right right because when this
stuff has happened
even in the comments when i did a video
on it right there were so many comments
saying like yo i never heard about this
like wow that's [ __ ] nuts sure it's
not gonna get like the same kind of
media attention
um but you know that's kind of like the
story of asians
the plight of asians in general right
it's just kind of
quiet suffering you know for the most
part yeah i think that's the hard thing
for a lot of people to process right
because when they saw
the whole blm movement happen and they
saw visibility for people who were being
murdered out in the streets
i think a lot of asian americans thought
like yo when this happens to us because
we were in support of blm
this is going to be reciprocated back
and now this country knows that you
can't just [ __ ]
with people like that and then when it
happened to an asian american everybody
just kind of turn
turn their shoulders or just kind of
turn the other cheek yeah and it was
like shocking for a lot of these young
kids right because
a lot of you young kids out there a lot
of young asian americans out there that
are seeing this right now
because of your age you haven't seen
this happen to us multiple times it has
happened
a lot so for when this happened i wasn't
shocked i'm a little older than you guys
i'm not that shocked like it's always
we've always been the sideline story
no matter what no matter when this stuff
happened so
i think a lot of these kids are like
well what about this proactivism that
happened i thought it was going to be
reciprocated or returned
but that also shows the behavior and and
the uh
the the idea that people have of asian
americans a lot of people don't take us
seriously
it's a reality check it's a reality
check right because you see
all of this you know proactiveness in
terms of um
bringing an issue to the forefront and
and having it become a national movement
and like you just said to have that same
type of expectation just being a
minority yourself
if this ever happens to our group of
people than
seeing what we've seen seeing how it
seems like we're in a more progressive
culture now
but then it's like well that sucks
that's what really that's the but hold
up my friends this podcast is brought to
you by
ipvanish for those of you who don't know
ipvanish is a vpn or a virtual private
network
that helps you safely browse the
internet listen up
simply put if you are on your computer
doing just about anything and you don't
have a vpn
you are [ __ ] nuts ipvanish is
something that you need being online is
fun but your data is
everywhere and having it encrypted is a
must you have to keep your personal data
and information
encrypted you cannot be just giving it
out to just anybody and you don't even
know who's looking at it
here's everything that you get with
ipvanish anonymous ip
addresses this means your personal ip
address can't be tracked by
anyone on the web you can circumvent any
online censorship
and you can get protection when using
public wi-fi so basically nobody can
snoop on your data or see what you're
doing online so go to ipvanish.combrain
claim your
65 savings they have plans starting at
just
349 a month super cheap or 27.99 a year
and yes it is worth it this is the time
to sign up ipvanish is the best of the
best and it even has
a 4.7 out of 5 rating on trustpilot
that's actually really hard to get
remember it's ipvanish.combrain to get
the deal
and protect yourself online that's
ipvanish.com
brain again it's a reality check i mean
and it really is kind of like a
commentary
on society that asians just are not
quite there yet in terms of getting
recognition or respect
right i mean there's already that
argument within entertainment
how asians never had kind of equal
representation
and we're just now starting to chip away
at that little by little
but in a human rights standpoint
right we're still it's still not it's
still not there
yeah and you know when i you i was
you know seeing a lot of this too they
were you know people were bringing up
trump again the former president of the
united states when they were saying
when he said china virus he put a green
light on a lot of asians
sure for sure that is very true however
i there's a there's a deeper thing
behind that is that
these sentiments were already there yeah
he just kind of
bolstered that idea before it's like
that stuff doesn't happen unless there
was already a foundation laid before for
it to be that effect
right right and so you know when we
don't get taken seriously
it's it's a really hard pill to swallow
right because
it's it's like i always ask it's like
well what do you want like what do you
want us to
right do we have to start busting
windows start burning [ __ ] down for you
guys to take us seriously
and i don't think that not number one
not that it's not in us it's definitely
there i mean we've had revolutions and
rights in in all over asia right we've
seen it happen multiple times in
wars however it's
i don't want to see our culture do that
and it's very hard to see that happen
with an older generation
because of these people that are being
taken advantage of the
the elderly and older people i think
they have this this
idea and thought of like graciousness
they're very grateful to be
in america and no matter what happens to
them here it's still better than
where they were before yeah so even to
that extent
like complaining or reporting crimes
isn't going to happen because for them
it's like
whatever like a great example of this is
like i had my friend
b new in like she she's a a one fc
fighter and she just told this really
small story
that kind of really does put a
perspective into how
a lot of asian immigrants view this
country who did come from like war-torn
countries or they lived in villages
like she was talking about she moved to
like east oakland east oakland is
[ __ ] hood and ghetto as [ __ ] and you
know you're living with
on on food stamps and you're living in
an apartment with like five or six
people and then people are complaining
that they're poor and the only thing she
thought was like
i have ac you know what i mean it's like
i'm living in luxury right
so you have these these type of people
who really do love this country to that
type of extent
and you expect them to complain about
the small things that they're going
what's which they consider small not to
us
is probably not going to happen yeah i
mean another thing to
really consider too is like um
in this country historically look at how
asian people in general
have kind of been viewed um you know
back from the chinese who were building
the railroad right
the caricatures that we used to see
i mean it kind of stems from that and
then um
you know the the internment camps for
the japanese
right uh that i feel like
doesn't get talked about as seriously as
it should be
yeah as it should um that was a that was
pretty
it was pretty [ __ ] yeah that was
pretty [ __ ] up you know i mean granted
it wasn't like
you know a nazi camp right that was
obviously far more heinous but
even stills it was kind of persecuting a
group of people because of their race
specifically and then you look at kind
of the stereotypes of asian men
asian women it's not very positive right
asian women
are looked at from uh kind of this
submissive yeah submissive uh you know
like tight [ __ ] exhaust like you know
what i mean you're not really licked as
a human being you just kind of looked at
it as this um
this prize yeah you just like this uh
just chunk of meat right and then what
are asian men
right stereotypes oh you got small dicks
you guys are [ __ ] right like
and so look at all this negative
connotation that exists
in american society of the asian people
and the fact that the whole being
subservient thing
is not just towards asian women but just
the asian community in general yeah
i mean it was a compliment for japanese
back in what the 40s and the 50s to be
called an
honorary right you're like you're an
honorary white person
right and that makes you good because
you just do what you need to do
you don't you don't talk back you don't
give a [ __ ]
you just do whatever the hell it is that
you ching chung
and as a result we'll give you the title
of being an honorary white
yeah and so like that's you just kind of
look at the history of that
of like asian people in america and and
it's no mystery why
we're just just kind of just in the
background we're not it's weird because
these
asian ideals that a lot of people
have that in my opinion or for a lot of
asian people
it's number one a smarter way to deal
with people coming at you and you know
saying these like negative things about
you
is not perceived as a sign of strength
in this country right so for example
like
pacifism like oh if you're a pacifist
you're a [ __ ]
that's what americans think in this
country right but to put it in
perspective like this and what i don't
think a lot of people understand and
this is the perspective that my parents
had
right when a lot of racist [ __ ] would be
said to them like or some terrible
things would happen to them they go
i'm better than these people why would i
even speak to them you know
and it's it's so funny how in asian
culture is like
you don't really speak to somebody at
the level
that you're at if you if they're beneath
you right and so what they see that is
oh this person's a [ __ ] because they're
not saying anything
but a lot of asian people in our culture
if we don't think that you're somebody
that we should [ __ ] with
it's not because we're scared it's cause
like it's like we're talking to a dog
you know if somebody comes at you and
says racial epithets
goes ching chong you're a [ __ ] blah blah
blah blah but you're coming through here
you're shopping at my store
it's like my dad's like most customers
aren't like that yeah it's that two
percent that comes in and those people
aren't even on our level right they're
not on the level of the other customers
in the store and they're not on my level
so why do i even get mad it's that
concept of like
when a dog howls at the moon does a moon
help matter it doesn't
you know well and especially when you're
korean too
because like you know korea's history is
pretty [ __ ] up in terms of like us
getting persecuted so
we've been persecuted for being korean
even by within the asians
you know by the japanese by the chinese
so
um you know having kind of like
i'm not saying there's no sensitivity to
racism
but it's such a long part of korean
history yeah and so like it doesn't
i guess it doesn't phase him yeah it
doesn't faze him as much as it would for
like somebody who grew up in america
oh
and like racism too is is such a
race and color is a is an idea and a
topic that is discussed a lot in this
country specifically for sure you talk
to a lot of other people in other
countries they don't talk about it as
much as
as americans do like the the racial
identity crisis
it happens a lot over here so you know
based on american standards people see
these
asian people or asian americans as
pacifists but when you look at it from
our perspective or
my you know my parents perspective it's
like listen i work hard
i make money i provide for my family
somebody comes who calls me a dog
that i eat dog and they call me ching
chong it's like that's all that they
have yeah like
how the why the [ __ ] would i get mad at
somebody who is not even at my
level but you see the difference though
right that's that's that's kind of the
whole difference behind like the
immigrant mentality yeah like i came
here for a purpose
you know and to an extent i've gotten
what i was hoping to get
like you just said like my family's good
you know i got a job
i got a home i got clothes on my back i
got food
i'm okay but then you look at kind of
the
entitled mentality that a lot of
americans have who
has who have never traveled before who
have never been outside of their bubble
here
and ignorance plays a big part of it and
and so like for them
they're coming with that that's that
ignorant energy you know what i mean
and then for like somebody who's had to
sacrifice
and compromise so much to get to another
country
just like you know it's like yeah that
sucks but
whatever yeah whatever you know what i'm
saying like
they think that is is a sign of weakness
but it's more like
hey [ __ ] you dude straight it's like
you're not even worth my time and so i
think
for a younger generation when you guys
see that and you look at your parents
and you're like well you should have
said something
it's like you don't even know what your
parents have went with you don't know
what's going on in their mind yeah it's
like and you know for you to be in your
level of comfort
and then kind of dog an older generation
for not
doing your form of activism it's a
different time
and i think it kind of sucks because
sometimes you know kids think
that their parents set a precedence for
asian people to be bullied
but they didn't you didn't have to worry
about the stuff that they had to worry
about
right and once again it's because of
these asian ideals and these agents
these confucius taoist beliefs
that just don't translate well over here
and so like i said and you know in my
purse
in my personal video that it on
instagram is that people have taken like
our like sympathy and our pacifism as a
sign of weakness when it was the exact
opposite
[Music]
asian people are business owners well
you know they make money they're [ __ ]
fighters too
yeah you have to fight to get what you
got here 100
yeah so it's not i wouldn't say you know
they're they're necessarily passive
right um
because yeah you had to do a lot of
[ __ ] fighting to get what you got
here
and and part of that fighting is against
racism as well
yeah so it's more of like uh the strong
and silent type
i mean because look man when i was
growing up like my parents didn't want
me getting into fights but when i got
into fights
my dad would ask me did you win at least
i know you know what i feel like that's
more of a korean thing
and like hey if you fought you fought
i'm not happy about it but did you win
at least yeah right
of course i did yeah like yeah
you know what's um kind of funny about
that whole thing too is like
when we talk about like uh fighting and
i think a lot of people think that
standing up for
your rights per se as because of the
the cultural milieu of what's happening
right now in this country people think
that you have to fight for your rights
through violence
yeah but there's also small subtle
things that you can do
right for example and i know it's hard
it's hard because sometimes
you're kind of going through this
balance of number one am i being too
sensitive
or is this the time it place to go ahead
and bring some of this stuff up right
so for example when you hear somebody
makes like racist asian jokes
and you kind of sit there and you don't
say anything
depending on the situation right as
everybody's having fun and you can make
fun of their race too
then that's just a good time right you
know gauge those situations
but there's small things that you can do
that'll show
that you don't have to take [ __ ] just by
saying
hey cut that [ __ ] out you think that you
have to be like me where i'm in
everybody's face and cursing somebody
else i actually don't do that a lot in
person
if i do that to somebody in person it
usually means we're about to throw down
yeah or some shit's about to happen
right
but it's just small [ __ ] like this like
i'll be having a conversation
and um like for example this happened
like a few years back right there was a
white dude
that dated an asian girl right and i met
him
um through like this this company thing
he used to work at this uh this company
that was attached to
and he made asian jokes simply because
he thought he had a green lights
because he went out with an asian girl
right and
i didn't like it but now a part of me
thought like hey
if i say like you'll cut that [ __ ] out
i'm probably gonna be a buzzkill because
it's around other people yeah
right so i have to i had to go ahead and
balance that [ __ ] out and so what
i decided to do was you know after he
made a few jokes and you could tell a
few people are uncomfortable
yeah i took them aside i was like hey
bro cut that [ __ ] out yeah like nobody's
laughing yeah like
i know you are the asian girlfriend and
[ __ ] but still inappropriate yeah it's
like
don't do that [ __ ] read the room my man
yeah like read the room
and cut that [ __ ] up i wasn't yelling at
him i wasn't being hyper aggressive
but i was letting him know like hey cut
that [ __ ] out
or i'm gonna have to check you right and
i did check him in a very nice way
and he stopped that stuff you can do
small things like that sure
it's hard right and i think a lot of the
times people are afraid to be
uncomfortable because of how weird it
makes you feel but growth doesn't happen
when you're comfortable
it happens when you're uncomfortable
absolutely absolutely because it's human
nature to want to be
out of that you know uncomfortable zone
right you put your hand over fire what's
your reaction
you take it away yeah you don't want to
get burned you don't want to feel that
discomfort
and so yeah that is really a big thing
is is taking action
like just on small things yeah just
yourself right you can't you can't sit
there and get angry about things
or you know feel a certain way about
things but like when you see
before we continue my friends let's talk
about purple
one of my favorite favorite sponsors
ever because i love my purple
mattress yeah if you think your bed is
good sure
if you put sprinkles on a piece of
dookie guess what
still a piece of dookie well guess what
the purple mattress
is the sprinkle not that poopy let's
talk about it for a second the purple
grit sets the purple mattress apart from
every other
mattress it's a patented comfort
technology
ever since i've had my purple mattress i
have never slept
so dang good in my life and when you
sleep well
your brain functions better you actually
are a lot healthier and it's been proven
to improve your life in so many
different ways you have no idea you
actually spend
a lot of your life sleeping so why do it
in pain why do it in discomfort
get on this purple mattress and in fact
if you get one who knows
i may be there with you in your bed only
if you like
if not i'm just okay this is getting
weird let's continue
this anyways guys experience the purple
grid and you'll sleep like never before
go to purple.com
gb10 and use promo code gb10 for a
limited time you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com
gb10 promo code gb10 for 10 off any
order of 200 or more terms apply
that type of negativity happen and
you're around it you just
well i mean yeah i'm not i'm not gonna
say anything because i feel weird if i
say something
and listen i'm gonna be honest too like
when there are situations too where
sometimes people say some weird [ __ ]
about asian people and i'm just
exhausted i don't want to say anything
you know and sometimes people get a pass
on it depending on the situation it
depends on your mood too
yeah like sometimes i want i want all
the [ __ ] heat
let's [ __ ] go yeah you know but other
times i'm just like i'm too tired to
deal with this [ __ ] but i got my own
[ __ ] going on right now bro
and next time i won't i won't give this
person a pass yeah
but there's like small little things
that you can do on the day-to-day type
of stuff right
don't be a buzzkill read the situation
like if everybody's clowning on each
other and they're making race
jokes i'm okay with that yeah right it
happens all the time like especially
where i grew up somebody made a [ __ ]
asian joke i made a black joke or a
white joke or a mexican joke and
everybody was laughing right but if
you're the only person that's getting
picked on and simply because of your
ethnicity and you're asian
and then you might have to say something
and you might be in those uncomfortable
situations where you have to figure out
like yo
uh last time i did this i was
overreacting and now everybody hates me
yeah but you're not gonna
be able to navigate those social
situations until you try yeah
i mean i told you bro i got into so many
[ __ ] fights when i was in elementary
because like the the racist white kids
yeah
i'm not even gonna go as far as calling
them racist ignorant white kids
yeah you know they just uh you know
making fun of like the food that i eat
the language you know
and like bro i i could not let that [ __ ]
slide even being a first grader second
grader whatever
like it offended me to the point like
we're [ __ ] throwing hands yeah
to the point that sometimes i'd fight
kids much older than me and get my ass
whoop
but it's like dude i just need to hit
you once that's all i'm trying to do
you know yeah because what you said is
[ __ ] pissing me off like
but i'm not saying to to resort to
violence like that but i'm saying
it's you got to step up for yourself in
that way
if what you just mentioned if somebody
is like clowning on you your your
heritage your culture whatever
and it's just you alone nobody else is
is
you know laughing except that well no
everybody else is laughing except you
yeah then that's a pretty good sign
where you got to stand up for yourself
there you know by saying something but
throwing a [ __ ] you know and i
know it and i know it's hard to because
it's easier said and done for somebody
like me that grew up in an area where a
majority of people
were of color yeah yeah a good
in my school it was like over like 30 or
40 percent people were asian so it's
easier
you know it's hard for that kid out
there in [ __ ] butt [ __ ] middle of
nowhere
you know and you're in a place called
[ __ ] chickenfoot wisconsin
bro you know what the most ironic [ __ ]
about that is man
is when i faced that type of like
ignorance
that was when we actually moved into a
decent neighborhood
like from k-town to like uh i lived in
la palma for a little bit
that's because my parents were starting
to
do okay for themselves and then so it
was like the first house that they
that we got but isn't that [ __ ] the most
ironic right like
you're getting out of poverty and you're
getting out of like you know
all of this crime or whatever and then
you get there and it's like that's
the most miserable i was like you know
like dude these [ __ ] kids are hating
on me like on a daily basis
yeah um and i
you know i just i just found that ironic
because like i don't think my parents
would have really expected that or
thought that would have happened
because they're thinking i'm i'm trying
to give my kid a better life yeah put
him in a better surrounding around
better schools
did you hear about that story about the
um
the white family that moved into a
mainly vietnamese neighborhood i think
it was out in the oc
westminster westminster you heard about
that yeah around there right
but you heard about that but did you
hear about so this this white family
moves in right yeah
and they started making like asian
racist jokes to the
their
probably west missouri but it's like the
whole neighborhood is vietnamese
right and and there's a certain group of
vietnamese people out there
and so the crazy thing is it's like it's
not just the the parents right it was
like the kids too because like the
the owner of the house like the father
or whatever he's out there in the
backyard and
the kids are calling him a peeping tom
they're making like racist jokes at him
like dog eater or whatever in a heavily
and so um i guess like the neighborhood
the the neighbors in the neighborhood
wanted to go ahead and make a protest to
show them like yo this [ __ ] is not okay
right wow that's a they're getting a
huge passage just a protest
yeah i thought they might get stabbed
there's probably a nicer area yeah
and then you know um the cops shut it
down because that it was like an
unlawful gathering of people
of course and so they're like okay cool
guess what it's a block party now yeah
and so it's the same [ __ ] but now it's
labeled the block party and the cops
came over and then escorted that family
out while the
while the block party was happening and
it's [ __ ] amazing it's like
even when they're wrong right they get
special treatment from the cops yeah and
it blew my [ __ ] mind and of course
later on it started the kids started
getting scared because
you know people were [ __ ] with them
at school you [ __ ] with the wrong
people
yeah and then i guess the parents were
like hey like is it possible for us to
issue a public apology and they're like
nah
yeah no too late for that you said all
the racial epithets your [ __ ] kids
were harassing this person and the only
reason why you want to it's not because
you feel bad
is because now you're scared and you
damn well should be you know
but that's that but this and the reason
why i bring that up too
is because could you imagine how bold
and safe you feel as
a white family to move into an almost
all asian american area and not
feel that your life is going to be taken
from you and again the important thing
is how entitled they feel
yeah you know it's uh yeah i mean that
that
that kind of sums it up right there
that's something like that's how little
they think
of asian people it's like if i did that
nothing is gonna happen
right it's like they're asian people
what are they gonna do they may not say
it out loud
but that type of behavior is reflective
of that right because i guarantee you
they wouldn't be going saying that [ __ ]
in a mexican neighborhood
no you know they would have making
[ __ ] jokes to some mexican people
because they'd be scared yeah but and it
just goes back to show how little they
um how little a lot of these people in
this country
um do not take like asian americans like
seriously again
look back like okay let's let's even
just say like gangs
right stereotype for asians if you're a
asian gangster
then you're a [ __ ] joke you're not
you're not you're not for real
little do people know like there's
plenty of [ __ ] asian gangs out there
that
you do not want to be around and you
sure as hell not
would not say some of those things that
you would say um
if you knew what type of people these
people are dude bro
let me let me tell you guys man uh back
in the day in the 90s right
there's a lot of people who found this
out in a very very bad way
because a lot of asian americans because
they were bullied and there's a lot of
asian americans who came to this country
that came from war-torn countries i'm
talking about they saw their neighbors
killed
people getting their hands and their
[ __ ] heads chopped off with machetes
yeah and so
a lot of these other asian american
gangs found out
oh [ __ ] these asian people are [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] savages
they're not just shooting us they're
actually chopping our [ __ ] heads off
and leaving them on railroad
tracks it was [ __ ] like that you know
what i mean
so i'm saying that's what i'm saying be
very [ __ ] careful because there might
be a tipping point because if you want
violence the violence is there
it's there like it was kind of crazy i
remember just watching like these these
docu series on like uh
um asian gangs and stuff and they're
like yo and there was other gang members
in the area like yo these asian people
are [ __ ] crazy like we thought we
could [ __ ] with them
we're talking about killing people these
guys are like [ __ ] dismembering us
yeah you know not even on some serial
killer [ __ ] it's just
that's just how it is that's how they
roll yeah you know like we we shoot one
of theirs and they chop up
our yeah ten of ours they [ __ ] chop
our heads off and [ __ ] like with
machetes and [ __ ] and they also got guns
which is nuts
and i'm not saying that that's the route
that i want but if you don't want to
take
the pacifist route seriously then what
other option is there
so make your choice right you keep on
pushing people into a corner you're
going to see what happens this is not
what i want
right but there's a lot of people out
there that don't understand it doesn't
matter who you provoke
everybody has it in them to retaliate
yeah man
look at daily riots just look at the l.a
right
what happened yeah like the the korean
businesses and community was attacked
and so what did they do
it's like all right we gotta [ __ ]
band together get our [ __ ] guns out
like we don't want to use it but you're
making us use it yeah and
we're gonna protect ourselves and our
community and our business now
and they didn't know that a lot of these
korean agencies at the time in korea
during that time
every korean male citizen four years
mandatory military service
you actually [ __ ] with people who were
in the military you didn't know
that you just thought that they were the
nice neighborhood asian people
and then you found out that every
[ __ ] asian guy knows how to use an
automatic weapon and really
they got like three straps at least yeah
and they're strapped the [ __ ] up they're
like yo how the [ __ ] these people know
how to use guns because they were in the
military for four
[ __ ] years you didn't even know that
[ __ ]
yeah what i'm saying is like that type
of stuff can't happen i don't want it to
be that way
right for sure but why should we tell
him and it's like why should we even
have to explain ourselves like that
why why does it have to even get to that
point i i don't understand and
again why does it have to be that you're
attacking elderly people who are so
[ __ ] defenseless and so helpless and
like the smallest thing could like be
the tipping point where their life is
over yeah you know what i mean listen i
saw my grandpa fall down on some ice and
number one actually was hilarious
but just to give you perspective of how
frail they are like just
had a bruise on his ass for like [ __ ]
three months that [ __ ] would not go away
that's that's a that's all he came away
with i mean that's that that's fortunate
you know
he like fell on his well first of all
like
i'm not proud of this yeah but i've
warned that old man multiple times and
stopped going outside and you know this
fool is like calling me an idiot because
i'm super young
you know he's like what the [ __ ] do you
know you know you young ass whatever
whatever yeah
and then you know sacramento gets really
cold and so the deck kind of has a
little bit of frost on it i'm like
don't go outside cause i'll do whatever
the [ __ ] i wanna i'm [ __ ] 90 years
old you know he's cursing at me and
creating my
eye man and i just see this fool through
the screen door
just kind of teetering over with his old
ass and then i see him go
up he's just like trying to catch
himself
falls on his ass and i was like i told
you and i picked him up and he had a fat
bruise on his ass and he never did it
again
but that's how frail old people are man
yeah dude that
honestly that could have ended his life
if he felt the wrong way i did not think
about that now you made me feel really
bad
you know what i mean i just got really
mad because he kept calling me fat
but yeah that that ages were like you
know
a fall for a normal person a relatively
young person where it's like nothing
could break their hip or like you know
cause some hemorrhaging in their [ __ ]
head
you know what i mean like it could be
fatal well a lot of people don't even
understand this is like
and i think this is going to be
enlightening for you know people who
aren't around asian americans in general
it's like
i know a lot of you guys out there in
your culture probably say
oh yeah i love my gam gam and i love my
papa
or whatever i don't know what the [ __ ]
you gotta say but
it is
you know asian americans have this
reverence
for our elders right and it stems from
how we address people
so in a lot of asian languages the way
we address elders depending on their age
all have different words and phrases and
sayings this is how important
age is to us right me being a younger
person like if
if edric was if we were like in korea i
would never address him by his name i
would have to call him hyung because
he's older than me
age is something that's very important
for sure seniority hierarchy
yeah like it's not just the [ __ ]
number to us right so when you get as
old as
you know a grandparent has and you know
mind you they're not like serial killers
and murderers and disrespectful
they're you know respectable members of
the community
um when when people pass away because of
like
taoist and confucius beliefs that stems
from hundreds of hundreds of years ago
whether you're christian or whatever
what not
it's still here till this day um for
korean americans we have our korean
thanksgiving which is called chushuk
right and during chuseok we actually
bring um our grandparents their favorite
foods
and we present it to them for them in
the afterlife then we burn incense
right and that is from those confucius
and taoist beliefs that's still here
until this day
these are the people that you have
chosen to attack in our community these
are people that we
highly respect it's not that they're
just old and [ __ ] and they're gonna
die and leave us what
you know whatever even to this like
people don't understand
putting asian that's this is why when
you go to your asian homies house you
still see grandma and grandpa living
with them
is because there's we have such a high
reverence for our elders
it's hard to put them in a home we just
can't do it i feel like
for for american people like yeah put
them in a home they have their own life
we don't have that yeah we have this
idea that we want them
to live happily as possible so by the
time they get old it's our position to
go ahead and take care of them your
responsibility and your duty
right and and it's like it's built into
the culture
especially if you're in kind of like the
position where your first born child
first first-born son um then yeah once
your parents get to
a certain age then you take care of them
no matter how burdensome it may be
no matter it's burdensome yeah no matter
how much your wife
may not like the idea um unless
you know they're the the grandparents
are on that tip
of like i could take care of myself i
refuse to let anybody take care of my
grandpa's
nephew couldn't take care of nothing
dude that's always crack fat jokes
it was so [ __ ] funny because he was
getting older and his memory would go
away
i remember i came back from uh l.a and
um
it's me you know it's just hyundai's you
know grandson yeah he's like oh he comes
up and he passed me on the butt
and then i'm going walking away into the
living room and i just hear this phone
in the hallway talking to my mom he's
like who's the fat guy
[Laughter]
oh man even with his
i still made him breakfast the next day
you know what i mean i still made him
his favorite foods i still took care of
him and that's what i did
yeah you know for for me too like and i
told the story before on this podcast my
grandma had
uh severe alzheimer's like she couldn't
remember anything
at all and we wanted her to be with us
as long as possible but it got
to a point where we just couldn't take
care of her yeah right and what i mean
by that
it got to the point where she couldn't
feed herself so they had to put a tube
into her stomach
just to put in food yeah that is the
extent that it took for her to not live
in our household yeah that we had to put
her in a home yeah
but even then and i don't think a lot of
people even do this and i know this
because i went to the home a lot
um i saw my grandma at least five
times a day and checked up on her at the
home for at least 20 to 30 minutes every
day
right even if she couldn't recognize me
that's how important our relationship
was
right and even the people at the nursing
home was like wow we see you a lot here
like a lot of people don't visit their
grandparents like you do yeah right
because a lot of people at that home
weren't asian they weren't asian
american so when i went there
i went there to go take care of her a
lot and then after my grandmother passed
which was really really hard uh my
grandpa lived with us at home and he
lived with us till the day he passed
away when he was like 98
97 years old and i had to make him
breakfast every day
at the school even though i lived
somewhere else i had to go and check up
on him to see if he was fine
i had to do all this other stuff and
it's it's something that's a part of my
you know duty right right i mean it's
it's the values we were taught and
that's ingrained in us right the family
values
yeah um and it's so important like
within
asian culture um i i would say like
american culture is a little bit
different when it comes to that type of
thing
you know i would say it's more common
where it's like oh you know as soon as
you turn 18
you you sporting yourself you figure it
out yourself but then
exactly yeah in the asian culture it's
like no we want to take care of that's
our children
so for as long as we can possibly try to
take care of them
then we want to try to do that um so you
know
very different values and and you and i
are kind of spawns of like the hybrid
right yes like
we grew up in america so we are
americans but we still have that
that asian culture instilled in us
because our parents were immigrants and
our grandparents were immigrants
and they didn't really um assimilate i
guess
so to speak to american culture they
maintained that
and then they kind of passed it on to us
and it caused us a lot of confusion and
maybe some trauma but yeah
yeah that's what we deal with you know
yeah i mean our position on everything
is very
very unique and you know our next
generation
there's going to be less of us around
for sure right they're going to be more
american than they are going to be
korean
or asian american i really want to pass
that on to my kids too though
no that's why i'm just going to beat the
[ __ ] out of them
getting that [ __ ] ass whoop that's
part of that asian culture bro
um no but i i would really like to pass
on kind of like
some of the culture and the values and
the language onto my kids because
when i was younger man i always thought
man this is so stupid because like i'm
i'm here in america like what do i need
to know this [ __ ] for what i need to
learn this [ __ ] for
but i definitely appreciated it as i
started getting older and i was glad
that my parents just kind of forced that
on me and and
kind of made me keep at it right yeah
like even the language thing
of like me being forced to only speak in
korean at home
i [ __ ] hated it bro i was like dude
i [ __ ] speak english everywhere else
to
everyone else why the [ __ ] at home like
i just want to speak comfortably
but yeah i'm glad dude because it's
helped me in so many different ways that
i never would have imagined
um i feel like a lot of korean people
conversely um
to a lot of other asians korean people
didn't really give a [ __ ]
like they wanted you to speak korean
yeah because i know a lot of my other
asian friends like their parents
specifically
only made them speak english because
they didn't want them to get bullied
but then our parents bullied us at home
right they speak korean
yeah they're like i don't give a [ __ ]
what's going on in the outside world
in this house you speak korean like the
moment you step into this house
it's actually south korea yeah you know
we followed by korean rules and then
when you go out you do your american
[ __ ] yeah you know which you know like
we hate it at first right but now it's
like
muriel too she was surprised that i
could speak korean because a lot of the
korean americans that she met
didn't have any ounce of their culture
inside of them
at all whatsoever their parents don't
speak english yeah but they don't speak
korean which was a very i don't even
understand
how they communicated right but then
again i feel like you and i are
different because i think we actually
have conversations with our parents yeah
yeah which a lot of korean american kids
don't
they just kind of you know have the
typical conversation of did you eat
yeah what did you do today yeah what are
you doing for work are you healthy yeah
right but then i could have extensive
conversations with my parents
yeah you know for example is abe like
abe his his brother joe
and then his uh brother sam yeah they
all speak the most trashiest worst
korean ever
right and their mom doesn't really speak
any english at all
so the extent of their conversation that
they have with their mom is very [ __ ]
limited
isn't that such an interesting like
thing to observe though
right is is that like that's the dynamic
within
a lot of these asian or korean families
where
dude your parents don't speak any
english yet you're [ __ ] korean is
trash yeah so what was the dynamic there
and and like you just what you alluded
to is that the
interaction is so limited of did you do
your homework
did you eat uh go to sleep did you wash
up right
it's just real basic [ __ ] and kind of
sad when you think about it
it is really sad and that also
attributes to a lot of asian americans
not having a relationship with their
parents because it's lost in the
language
yeah right absolutely it's it's
literally the most
basic form of communication and there's
a lot to be said like for example like
i'm pretty sure abe and them
they don't actually know how [ __ ]
funny their mom is their mom is [ __ ]
funny
right and it's only i i know this
because i can actually speak to her
we joke around a lot you know but i see
how they talk
to their mom and it sucks because i'm
like damn you guys are actually missing
out on a
really cool relationship with your mom
yeah because she's [ __ ] hilarious
yeah and there are things that i know
about
their parents that even they don't know
right because their mom can't really
translate it to them and tell them
you know and that's why a language
barrier can be
so difficult to you know maintain a
relationship with
or to like to get into the the depths of
a relationship
even when it's your mom even when it's
your dad you know even when it's family
it's like yes i love this person
but do i really know this person you
know this person is my family we're
blood
they've taken care of me as a result i
feel a sense of like responsibility for
them
too but do i really know them as a
person
i think you know that's a it's really
common for like
our generation and and like our parents
generation and so on where they didn't
really
know who their parents were you know
it's like
yeah they're just your parents they're
your mom and your dad but who are they
as
people it's like i don't know because i
don't talk to them
yeah they don't start saying like
there's there's so much to be said
and to dive into that part of like the
the young asian american experience
because i always run to a lot of young
people who talk about like
oh my parents you know they just like to
yell at me and tell me what to do is i
guarantee you is because
you don't know how to talk to them yeah
not not in the sense of um
you being disrespectful rude it's just a
language barrier right right like
and the other way around too they don't
know how to talk to them either you know
because they just don't do well do this
you know like the most basic of basic
language stuff
the reason why i'm allowed to have a
relationship with my mom
is because we can speak i mean my create
isn't that great yeah but it's good
enough to where we could joke around
talk about things outside of the basic
stuff so
it's it's fun to have conversations with
her yeah right we can joke about she can
tell me stuff about herself
you know when she was younger yo she
told me this [ __ ] funny story the
other day
this woman told me this one quick story
about how when she was younger
she my mom is not somebody who is she's
a tomboy
super super tomboy right like she was
known to be a tomboy in her class and
everything else
she probably wasn't the brightest bulb
you know
but she was very violent so she told me
like one time
these kids kept on calling her like
tomato face right
and it's because my mom actually has
condition where she can't sweat
really yeah so when we were kids and we
would go to
these church events outside at the park
and and sacramento gets really hot
during the summer
i would always have to be there with an
ice pack and have to cool her down on
her neck
with an ice pack because she can't
develop sweat so she had to be
cooled down with like having water
thrown at her or like i would just throw
water
in her face but you know she would have
to get miss it or have an ice pack on
her neck
because if she did she would pass out so
the the actual function of sweating is
to actually cool our body down
she doesn't have that her sweat glands
don't work i forgot what that condition
is called
crazy so um when she was so when she was
in grade school a lot of these boys
would tease her
and so there's a story my mom told me
she was like yeah these boys used to
tease me a lot but then you know they
they stopped real quick after i beat the
[ __ ] out of them
i'm like well how did you beat the [ __ ]
out of them i'm like well you know like
these kids when they're the guys they're
young they'll make funny but that's
probably because they like you a little
bit yeah
so my mom was like hey let's go meet up
after school and like make out or
something
right and so the guy was like oh cool
yeah this is a guy that used to make fun
of her a lot
and so they kind of met up behind the
school and then she had like a rock and
then she just beat the living
[ __ ] out of them with it oh my god
she lit my mom as gangster as [ __ ]
jumped the guy for calling her tomato
face wow and so
i was shocked and so even when we went
to korea i remember this as a kid
because my mom went to go see some of
her friends that she hasn't seen in
years and i was like
what seven or eight at the time and
when she one of the things that i
remember the most was her meeting her
friends and her friend
and she looks at her and she goes oh hi
and they're all happy to see each other
they go
these are my two kids and the guy and
the lady looked at her and she was like
you got married you know they were
almost shocked because she was so rough
around the edges
i mean and so like this is the stuff
that a lot of people don't get to hear
about their parents
yeah these are like personal [ __ ]
stories yeah it's because i can't speak
the language well to nothing i can
understand
well another thing too uh which it
reminds me of is like
one of my exes before uh didn't have
like the greatest relationship with her
father
and um one thing that i realized
which is kind of common within asian
culture is that
they the kids look at their parents as
parents like that is mom that is dad
that is oma that is appa or or whatever
you know
asian uh you know ethnicity you might be
but
they don't look at their parents
necessarily as humans
like and i was trying to tell her like
just for
once just kind of separate the dad title
and just look at him as a human being
like somebody that has his dreams that
has his choice
that has his fears that has his feelings
that has his troubles
you know and and try to remove that
label
and just think about it as at him as a
human being
and then try to interact with him and
then try to talk with him under that
idea
and that was kind of like a really uh
eye-opening
i guess a suggestion for her and that
helped
to kind of have her take some steps
better steps with her dad to building a
relationship
but i think that's again a common thing
with a lot of asian kids is that they
don't look at their parents and and
think
like what if they're just human beings
not not my mom not my dad or whatever
and maybe they're just a friend or maybe
there's somebody that i'm just trying to
get to know a little better
and if i feel like when you kind of uh
yeah look at it from that perspective it
kind of changes how you think
about your parents and how you look at
them and as a result
you might be able to engage them in a
way that
you wouldn't have been able to before
because it's that mental block of that's
mom
that's dad that's it well i think a lot
of people too
they're gonna find out they find this
concept about uh a little too late
right is when they start when they start
to face their parents mortality
and that's the hard part yeah you know
you should probably do this before that
for sure right for sure because there's
a moment too that you'll see in your
parents
um a weakness that you never saw before
yeah vulnerability
vulnerability it's like where you see
your parents like oh [ __ ] they're hurt
yeah like they could possibly die yeah
like what the [ __ ] because
when you're a kid your parents are just
your rock they're your constant
so when you fight with them and you do
all this stuff you don't think that oh
this is going to be the last time i ever
get to speak to them yeah
it's just mom and dad are always going
to be here forever they're my
superheroes that's super mom that's
super dad
yeah and then when you're faced with
their mortality it's like
oh what what how much time have i wasted
fighting with these for sure
that's why my parents died we don't
really fight anymore yeah my dad
literally said he goes i only have like
20 good years left on this earth
yeah i'm not gonna do it fighting with
you like i'm done especially given the
circumstances right now
you know i mean [ __ ] man i've never been
so paranoid
in my life about like my parents
well-being because you know they're at a
at-risk dude we just had
a very close family friend my mom's best
friend and
and she was like family to us passed
away two days ago
from complications because of covid you
know oh wow and so like
[ __ ] like that hits home like dude that
and and like uh
that that uh you know well i mean i
guess like colorado but
her sons i'm friends with too so like
it's like dude
i feel that man like yeah that hits so
close to home because that's my mom's
best
my mom was crushed by it because like
she doesn't have any family here
all her family's over in korea and so
like not only is this person a best
friend but she was like a family member
to her
they've known each other for like 30
years you know
so you know it's devastating for her
and and for me you know like i'm i'm
like
really saddened by her passing but then
i'm also thinking about my parents like
oh
[ __ ] dude you guys can just as easily
have the same thing happen to you if you
don't continue to be careful you know
continue to take care of yourself
because you're at that point now you're
not young anymore you're not
you can't just [ __ ] you know will
yourself through these type of
situations
it's like it's that [ __ ] scary and
yeah dude mortality and in my parents is
something that i've been thinking about
more and more
you know i think time was like i
remember there's just one moment that
it hit me really hard and i think it was
like in my mid-20s or something like
that right it was
i i had i thought about this moment
where i remember being
in high school which wasn't that far
from where i was before
yeah and thinking that [ __ ] man these
days are so
slow why can't i just hurry up and be
summer right why can't it just be winter
break
every day felt like it felt like
molasses dripping right yeah
and then now it's i blink and then it's
another year
i blink and i look at my parents and i'm
like oh they got older
that's isn't that like the one of the
most kind of scariest and like
eye-opening moments for you you look at
the stage in their parents yeah you're
just like all of a sudden they just
[ __ ] got old
yeah and i'm like what happened and i'm
like oh well
i'm not any younger either now too yeah
you know
yeah that's trippy that was the weirdest
moment i remember i just i went back
home
because i was living in l.a at the time
and it was only like a couple of years
and i went back home and i looked at my
parents and i had
my canon 5d mark iii i was like i'm
going to take photos of my grandpa
and i lost those photos too good job
david and then i
i'm going to take photos of my parents
and i took a photo of them
and i saw it in the computer and i'm
like holy [ __ ] these people are [ __ ]
old yeah
and when i look back at these older
photos right when i was like eight or
seven years old
mentally my mental image is of that
person no for sure
right for sure and then i snap back into
reality i look at them now i'm like
bro that was [ __ ] 20 years ago and
it's it's so crazy how it's like sudden
you know what i mean out of this
progressive thing of like yeah you know
now they're in their 60s and
it's like yeah all of a sudden and it's
just like you said
you imagine how you imagined your
parents when you were younger
that's how they are until you have that
moment and then you're like
holy [ __ ] they're like senior citizens
yeah they're they're [ __ ] they got us
so old
yeah what happened like i said you
realize you're not young anymore either
yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] my back hurts
not going through the same problems my
dad did yeah yeah it's
that is one of those things that kind of
helps you kind of snap into reality for
sure
it's that idea of mortality i'm like oh
[ __ ] there's going to be a time
where i'm going to have to bury my
parents yeah and i see that and i saw
that a little bit when my dad had to
bury my grandma
and my dad had to bury his grandfather
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
and my dad's a person and he probably
went through these same thoughts
where when he was raising me and he's
like oh like my parents are a little
older they're
i have to take care of them and he had
to bury his parents there's gonna be
time where i have to bury mine then my
kids will have to bury me too
right and these thoughts too sometimes
it kind of goes down this rabbit holes
of
oh you know where the [ __ ] is time going
no for sure like how fast is time going
what am i doing with this time am i
making it count what am i you know and
you know my anxiety gets the best right
you're just going to spiral yeah like
give me some [ __ ] weed right now yeah
for sure yeah
because i get worried sometimes too
where i think about the the time that i
waste
right and i'm in this point now where i
don't know
what wasting time exactly is or what it
entails
because um sometimes i think wasting
time is me just always working too much
yeah and sometimes while wasting time is
me not working enough at all
right and i just get stuck in this this
position where i just feel [ __ ] like bad
about myself
no i i i get it man i get what you're
saying and like
you know i spoke about this on my
instagram story recently but
it kind of reminds me of of the thought
that i had um which was
you know i i had my birthday was uh last
week
right and it was the first time that i
ever spent my birthday alone but i was
it was fully expected
well i mean to an extent but yeah i mean
we're in a pandemic whatever
and then so zee asks me hey what are you
going to do for your birthday this year
yeah what the [ __ ] am i going to do what
would you ask me that [ __ ]
nothing right and then he's like what
did you do last year
and and i couldn't [ __ ] remember man
i was trying to think
like what the hell did i do last year
who were the people that were there with
me last year
and it's just like all of these kind of
like
memories from different birthdays were
just kind of like popping up but
i couldn't pinpoint when that was
and then it wasn't until he started
talking about
he started slowly remembering oh no i
think we were we ate here
and then we went there and i'm like oh
you're right yeah yeah okay and then it
started to kind of come up in my head
but i was like dude isn't it so [ __ ]
ironic
that you know you do these things
speaking of time given
like the idea of time being limited you
don't want to waste it so you do these
things to create memories to create
experiences and and try to like get
yourself out there
yet i can't [ __ ] remember
a damn thing i did for my birthday
celebration
i couldn't even [ __ ] remember where i
was who i was
with like who i was with i could make
guesses at right
just just by assuming okay these are the
people in my life or whatever so these
people are probably there but then
the fact that i couldn't remember that
and the the fact that i'm sitting here
now
and and celebrated my birthday at home
[ __ ] eating cake by myself and you
know
my sister came to visit me my mom sent
me some food so it wasn't all bad you
know i got food sent to me whatever
but i'm just saying like the celebration
aspect of it was alone
and i didn't do anything and i'm like
dude i'll never [ __ ] forget this
birthday
yeah you know because i did nothing so
it's just like yeah
i just found that really ironic man
because like
even if the idea of having limited time
prompts you to act
prompts you to do things it's still so
easy to take for granted yeah and that's
another step
you know what i mean to realize you have
limited times to and
to do things but then to also really be
present
in that and appreciate what it is that's
happening because
when that's the norm like yeah even if
you're acting to do it it's so easy to
take it for take for granted
and i'm somebody who tries to keep
myself accountable of not
trying not to take things for granted
trying not to take situations people for
granted
but that made me realize man i still got
a lot of work to do to like really be in
the present and appreciate
the moments that i have the experiences
that i have with the people that i have
you know
um yeah man basically it sucks that
we're slowly dying but
that's that's what it is and you got to
make the most of it so
you know these thoughts are also very
good and healthy too because
i think it also kind of puts in
perspective of kind of why i do the
things that i do and why i've
chosen to make the moves that i've made
right
and sometimes i get into these moments
of like self-doubt words like
you know david if you just do these
corny little sketches and you know
follow the trends
you know you could just be like the
biggest guy and you know yeah whatever
you could you could do
you could literally do what all these
[ __ ] do right now and do it ten
times better
but then there's this idea that i have
of like how limited time is on this
earth right
and what i want to be remembered for
right what i want people to know
that i did when i when i lived here
right and it's definitely not pranks
it's definitely not following trends
like these things are not impactful in
the future
like what what stamp have you left on
anybody's life when you do these type of
things
and it stops me from doing it because it
just that to me feels like a waste of
time
you know so sometimes there's this
introspective thought of like you know
time going by
and you know making these things count
it actually does help me realign why i
do the things that i do right
why i started up a podcast why i um
decided to do a film and then drop
youtube for a year
and then you know make some of these
moves that weren't as profitable as
as before but whenever i get to look
back and i look at these choices i say
hey
you've made a positive impact in a lot
of people's lives and if you're going to
continue to do that and that's your main
goal then you shouldn't
feel bad about what the move that you've
made even though you could pay more
money yeah that's a good point i mean
it's
it's a really um about legacy
but also it's this idea of like
you're gonna exist in the ethers of like
the internet forever
yeah you know what i mean and that's
such a strange concept because we didn't
have that yeah we didn't have that for
the first half of our life
and the second half of life now it's
like oh [ __ ] this is permanent
you know like what i put out there will
exist
unless i remove it somebody could have
ripped it and put it up re-uploaded it
too
you know what i mean and so it'll exist
and it's somewhere in the internet
for for the rest of time or until the
end of this world
even and and it's like yeah what what
are you leaving behind
in in let's say the wake of like your
death
right it's like what then what what what
what i what am i leaving behind in the
world
and and it's like somebody that comes to
mind
when you talk about a scenario like that
is kobe what did he leave behind
that mamba mentality right when kobe
passed that was one of those things too
my man kobe right there yeah right here
bro you know colby
the crazy thing about kobe is like you
know [ __ ] you but i love you
which says so much about who he was
though there's so many people who hated
him when he was active as a player
but then after his death they found
themselves [ __ ] just broken
and crying it's crazy it's like i don't
know if i have this in me right
but i do want what kobe not has but what
he's done
right and what dave chappelle does right
there they're people who are cemented in
their beliefs and they stick it all the
way through yeah
and they've left in a very important
legacy right when i look at somebody
like
um the the the two white boy brothers
[ __ ]
my brain is dead logan paul jake paul
right
they have money they have notoriety and
fame but to me
they have zero legacy you know and
that's something i could really care
less for
like i i do generally feel like when
they die people a few people might cry a
little few tweens but they'll forget
about it the next day
literally like if they stop doing
youtube like tomorrow
nobody's really going to miss them yeah
somebody else will take that position
that he'll disappear because it's so
like trend heavy
you know you know what i mean like
literally temporary they they've own
like that's the stuff i don't want it's
not the spies it's more like
i could care less for i genuinely
believe those two people die they'll be
forgotten about in the next couple
months
they've done all this work to make all
to be recognized
in this in the now but it doesn't
transfer over to the future it doesn't
do anything else for the generation
after yeah it's just
they died oh i'm so sad they did i don't
know what did they do
and then people move on to the next big
star something like kobe
he passed away last year and it feels
like it was yesterday yeah
stuff that he has implemented in this
earth world right now
people still follow it they go do you
have mama mentality yeah
do you have mama mentality yeah it's
nuts yeah he's been gone a whole year
now and people talk about him like he's
still alive till this day yeah that's
gonna happen for michael jordan
it happens to every person on this wall
right now except for these two [ __ ]
over here
mike tyson yeah despite his shady past
right a lot of the stuff that he's done
a little bit precarious i might still
yeah
that's what he does you know what i mean
dmt i'm out of this
world you know sometimes i don't even
know where i'm at
see david people like you and me yeah
people like you and me
david you know a lot of people they just
wish that they could do what we
do but that's why they're
and then you have bruce lee the man has
been gone until this day
and people have ridiculous conversations
about bruce lee till this day because of
the legacy that he's left
behind water right like they're like oh
my god like
bruce lee could probably beat up every
ufc star even though it's not true yeah
you know people still want to believe it
because of a legend that he is right
you know not not everybody can go ahead
and do that but it doesn't mean that i
won't try to yeah exactly and that's the
type of legacy that i want to leave
look chasing perfection
doesn't necessarily have to mean because
you believe that you
realistically think you can achieve
perfection it's because you're just
striving to get to it as close as
possible
perfection is is is impossible you know
it's unrealistic
but it doesn't mean that you can't
strive for it to try to get as
close to that as possible so that when
you look back at the effort that you
made
you look back at it and think you know
what i gave it everything i possibly
could have
you know and i got i got to be able to
live with the results that i got from it
um and and so i feel like it applies to
what you're saying perfectly within what
you're doing
right whatever this concept of
perfection is
in terms of like leaving a lasting
legacy and leaving
something meaningful for the world
behind to to like
absorb and digest long after you've
passed and become dirt in the earth
what is that thing you know what what is
it that you're working towards
and obviously nobody could determine
that except you how it feels in your gut
like you just said
certain things that you've thought about
doing you passed on it because in your
gut
doesn't ring right it doesn't ring true
for you you're just like this is so
temporary i was supposed to be on wild
and out
my life would have been way different
yeah well that would have been yeah that
would have been pretty different for
sure
you better [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
what you got to do you know what i mean
i wouldn't have done well on that show
yeah i just wouldn't have liked the
people on there
yeah they're probably they're fine but
just there's the show i just couldn't do
it yeah
yeah that's the thing like nobody knows
yourself better than you man and so like
nobody can sit here and be like oh my
god i can't believe you passed on an
opportunity like
because they don't know what you're
feeling you know it's not it's not in
just like when dave chappelle left the
[ __ ] what 50 mil
yeah oh how can you [ __ ] leave 50 mil
with
little to like no regard of like
what the situation actually was what it
meant to him personally i mean he's
obviously elaborated that
on that a lot more in more recent times
but yeah it was just like
you're just thinking about it from your
perspective of oh my god 50 mil is such
a [ __ ] life-changing thing how could
you pass 50 million dollars
but it's like nah man it's like money is
not necessarily everything
fame is not necessarily everything
you're looking at it from such a limited
perspective which is
uniquely yours you're not you're not
looking at it from the person that it's
actually affecting
who has to make that decision and then
live with it you know
and so yeah i think just again
being present being mindful uh being
appreciative
i think those are all things that
applies to what we just talked about in
the past like 30 minutes
you know well guys that wraps up this
episode of the genius brain podcast
stop [ __ ] with asian people stop stop
[ __ ] beating on her i'm laughing
about it but i'm actually pretty [ __ ]
pissed
yeah well because it's just the idea of
it it's so ridiculous it's so [ __ ]
ridiculous
if if if i catch a [ __ ] man
i'm not gonna go there but you know just
stop i'm gonna beat you up in the most
asian way possible
i'm gonna throw ninja stars at your eyes
and i'm gonna beat your [ __ ] kneecaps
with nunchucks
please just stop please just stop man
not just [ __ ] asian elderly
just any elderly people just leave them
alone they're they
they've paid their [ __ ] dues in life
let them just exit gracefully
on their own will it doesn't it does not
have to be on [ __ ]
slamming into the pavement and just
being blindsided you know what i mean
that like that is
such a [ __ ] car i swear to god if i
ever see one of you [ __ ] i
swear and piss in your mouth
yeah well guys you could catch edrick at
ed park
no ed too sorry
ed two edtwo guys come on you don't mean
to buy now come on man
and then uh secret society yes and uh
brain
15 for first-time purchasers to get 15
off yep
so what you see these bomber jackets
that we have on the hat that was not
planned
i actually was about to wear the black
one today too but something in me told
me
i should wear the olive one instead when
i have sex after this
wearing these jackets and then we will
see you all
next time every sundays and thursdays
love you guys very much
peace peace